hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday April 20 [ __ ] 9th 2019 what's
going on how are ya oh all freckles is
in Iceland
Billy the red the old [ __ ] bald
Viking has returned to the motherland
you know it's funny as I've been growing
my beard out a little bit because I have
I have a little bit of acting work
everybody I got a part in a it's a
mini-series on lifetime
it's about verbally abusive dads and I
play the father and some of my lines are
you call this popcorn you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know so I've been working on it's
gonna be an edgy one it's gonna be the
first rated our Lifetime movie and
that's when I'm in and I'll be doing a
lot of screaming a lot of throwing of
inanimate objects at my wife my
television wife and television children
and they will like bill you know as much
as you have the anger in you we just
don't find you intimidating is there any
way you could grow out your red beard
and I said well certainly absolutely I
can do that so that's what I've been
doing so look for it there's the program
the working titles tend to live called
mommy can you can could you kill daddy
no I'm sorry I'm sorry I ran out of [ __ ]
to say anyways um I'm out here I've been
out here since last Monday spent a week
out here in Iceland and I've had such a
[ __ ] great time I don't even know
where to begin
had some family come out with me and my
wife and my daughter and some other
people came out and let's see I think on
Wednesday
Wednesday we went on a whale watch now
first of all my poor daughter she was
sick we thought she got airsick but she
just was sick sick she puked like
[ __ ] I don't know three or four times
on the way over and we only brought like
two changes of clothes but by the time
we get to friggin Iceland the poor thing
all she had was like her diaper on and a
friggin t-shirt that we bought in
Seattle we connected in Seattle and my
wife was like I was looking for a little
Seahawks t-shirt for it thought that'd
be cute and I was like that would not
have been cute
so anyway of course we get to Iceland
and we get off the plane and it's one of
those deals where you get off the plane
and then walk over to a bus so I got her
all wrapped in a blanket and I was all
nervous she was gonna get even more sick
but it was just like a 24-hour little
stomach thing that she had and she's a
tough kid man she really is and I
figured growing up in Hollywood or
whatever
she's been loving it out here like she
cries when we bring her back inside like
she wants to be outside she's always
going wini wini saying it's like windy
you know and she loves it loves the cold
weather yeah she's a little she's a
tough kid she's at that age to where she
wants to do everything herself like we
did a couple of sightseeing things and
we were all going to get in the van and
my wife picked her up to put her in the
van and she got all upset going no no I
do it I do it I do it and she would
literally get out of the van and then
get back in and herself and spend like a
minute trying struggling trying to get
up into the bench seat with the kid
chair on top on I was just waiting for
you know when she gives up she goes Dada
help right and she didn't she just stuck
it out sat down and looked at us and
smiled like see I told you I could do it
I didn't say I could do it in under ten
minutes but I just said I could do it so
been having an awesome time she's got
some new words everybody is a new word
everybody swim everybody eat and then of
course while he's playing her jams my
favorite thing she says is she go
I want AI e io o McDonald man that's
that's our tomb so anyway the we landed
on Tuesday we didn't do anything you
know we were all jet-lagged and my wife
was able to stay up but me and my
beautiful daughter just passed out in
the bed for like six hours which is kind
of how I'd get over jet like I don't
fight it the first day because I feel
like if I fight it the first day that
I'm gonna get sick so I just go to sleep
and so anyway when Wednesday we went on
a whale watch and you know the deal with
the whale watch you go out and you watch
and you look for whales on the water and
I up growing up boss I never did it
never did it I've seen a couple of
whales flying a helicopter I'm you know
off the coast of Malibu but they just
like they look like little glow sticks
because we're so high up you know you
don't want to go down low and disturb or
whatever freaked him out so I have the
[ __ ] whale looking up like Henry Hill
looking for the helicopters yeah so I'd
never done it so we went out there and
the captain said at the end of the trip
he said I've been doing this for 11
years I was a top five day we saw so
many [ __ ] whales I mean I don't know
if it was the same two or whatever I
don't give a [ __ ] it was incredible
they were feeding on there was a bunch
of whatever whatever the hell they eat
out there
plankton or some fish I have no ideas
our plankton fish I don't know
you know is it land lover or land lubber
and if it's lover because I've seen both
it written both ways I don't know what
the [ __ ] that is you just saw you know
the spray going up then we went over
there and they cut the engine and we
just sat there and watched these things
just coming up for food one one time
came up and its mouth was open they
weren't doing that thing where their
tail kept coming out of the water
because they were feeding so we just you
just see him kind of do like a arching
that back coming out of the water and
then a school of dolphins came by that
had like white on them on their body
like on the tips of their fins or
something at Jesus Christ can those
things [ __ ] fly they were all over
the place they were racing with the with
the boat zigzagging in front of the boat
I felt like I was in a movie I said then
we go to go fishing which I gotta be
honest with you I'm a carnivore I don't
like killing animals I just don't like
doing it and it's weird but I'll eat him
if someone else killed him you know like
I feel like if I was in a gang I would
be the getaway driver
like guys I don't want to go into the
bank and put my gun in somebody's face
but I'll take the money you steal my
heart's just not in it
[Music]
which is why you know it's really
[ __ ] weird so my thing is is if I'm
gonna kill an animal I'm gonna [ __ ]
eat it and I'm gonna eat the whole
goddamn thing and I'm not gonna waste it
or anything because I remember a long
time ago I went both fishing and we shot
a bunch of [ __ ] you know it turns out I
was a lefty with the bow and arrow and I
was actually pretty good at it
and I shot a [ __ ] alligator gar and I
remember we brought it up onto the boat
and I thought I was as badass and they'd
go watch that thing nothing will [ __ ]
you know rip your leg open and stuff and
I shut it through the back third of its
body and after a while I was just like I
would kill a lot of fish are we gonna
eat these things and they just they just
to rule them all back and they were like
that thing's gonna be fine it's clean
he's gonna be fine I shut it through its
[ __ ] body and it just it just didn't
fit I remember after once I found out we
weren't eating what we were shooting I
just stopped I was just like yeah I'm
good I'm good like what like what the
[ __ ] are we doing out here
so anyway we go to go fishing and Nia's
never fished in her life and they got
these fishing hooks and were they there
was like two on each line they put you
know some old [ __ ] fish on there
whatever rights bait I believe is what
the outdoorsman call it and you know me
and my buddy we'll both fish and we're
not catching anything Nia's never gone
fishing she dropped that line twice and
all of a sudden she's like oh my god
I think I got something I think I got
something she's like oh no and I see it
you know I see the rod bending I know
she's got something she [ __ ] pulls it
up she caught two fish with one [ __ ]
strike and she was freaking out she
thought it was awesome and then we went
to a different place to fish and I
dropped my line in I felt a bite and I
pulled it up and it was it was like a
trophy fish so biggest goddamn fish ever
God was a giant [ __ ] Cod I'll post a
picture of it and I mean the fish was
beautiful and you know took a picture
with what I would set it down I really
said sorry buddy and then we you know
cut it all up and all of that [ __ ] and I
ate three helpings of it to make sure he
ate the whole [ __ ] thing cooked it
right up on the boat and a little frying
pan right well with some butter on it it
was absolutely [ __ ] delicious and I
got oh man I just kept getting in my
head I was just like man this is such a
big one it [ __ ] that I just kill this
thing
this [ __ ] fish was beautiful it's in
the prime of its life I just I just
don't got it in me you know what I mean
I respect hunting and all of that [ __ ] I
think it's cool I like watching those
rogen things when he goes out and he
shoots elk and all of that stuff and I
he's given me some of that meat and it's
[ __ ] delicious I just don't I don't
got it in me I literally think I I would
feel less guilty if I shot a person
well depending on what the person did
but but I'm a hypocrite because they
[ __ ] I eat meat and [ __ ] and like the
next day we ended up going to we don't
went on this great trip we went out to
like these hot springs and [ __ ] because
I don't know like the lava or whatever
the [ __ ] is really close to the surface
out here I don't know what's going on
but they got all these [ __ ] hot
springs and it's literally like you know
can get upwards of 400 Gries Celsius or
whatever just like 800 Fahrenheit or
something like that something along
those lines between eight and nine
hundred degrees and we went we watched
those things and it was weird it was
like it was an amazing thing to watch
but it's like that's boiling water and
we're just standing here like [ __ ]
[ __ ] two feet away from it I mean
went to go out and go look at this
waterfall and on the way we stopped at a
farm that had a little restaurant I
ordered a burger and all that type of
[ __ ] and once again I went and I my
daughter was looking at the cows I know
like a burgers made out of a steer and I
was looking at the cows and I'm like
these things are [ __ ] beautiful
especially like the light brown ones
just gorgeous and I was just like the
[ __ ] am i doing and I said to me I go I
swear to god this trip is making me want
to go vegetarian for a minute I go well
can you believe why the [ __ ] do we eat
those things they're beautiful and she
couldn't eat ghosts because they're
[ __ ] delicious so I don't know but
what is cool about Iceland is you know
they have a lot of places where there's
like vegetarian like options and [ __ ]
and I don't know maybe it's just this
trip maybe it'll wear off I don't know
what cuz I do love a [ __ ] steak and
I'm at one time I watched this thing
just going these guys that [ __ ] lives
out in the frontier like it's still the
1800s and he had a bunch of [ __ ]
cattle
and all of his cattle were getting like
all banged up and [ __ ] he couldn't
figure out what it was you know is there
some animal trying to attack him at
night and he did all the surveillance
and it turned out it was one of his his
steers or his cows I can't remember what
the [ __ ] they were right and this thing
was just [ __ ] being aggressive and
bumping into him I got to the point he
had to get rid of the thing so he's
going alright so the key is is to try to
like you know just be like totally chill
and then you give them the right there
Fred so they're not nervous and that
whatever that nervousness does makes
their system acidic I don't know what it
does but it makes the meat not taste
good long story short he blows us things
[ __ ] brains out like when
what's-his-face Tommy goes to get made
and Goodfellas like the cows like oh let
me go over here I'll now bang and that's
it right closed casket
[ __ ] right in the head so then they
come over with like this [ __ ]
front-end loader right a little mini one
and they tie up the things back legs and
then they lift the the bucket up and
they got this [ __ ] steer like hanging
by its back legs and this guy starts
butchering it and at first I was
watching uh oh my god this is [ __ ]
horrific peels all the [ __ ] skin off
all of this [ __ ] chops to had in the
legs off and all of that and the more he
cut into this thing the less it became
gross and I started recognizing the cuts
of meat and I my mouth started watering
oh [ __ ] up is that I was like oh my
god that was a beautiful animal how
could you do that oh my god is that a
full leg ooh look at that ribeye by the
time he got down to it I was just like
and he was cutting these thick [ __ ]
steaks and it was like his fries is
gonna be full you eat that [ __ ] thing
for the next four years so I don't know
I don't know where I order I I really I
guess I'm saying I get both sides I
totally get not wanting to [ __ ] eat
an animal because they're [ __ ]
beautiful and then what the [ __ ] did
they do but on the other side as my wife
says they're [ __ ] delicious
they really doesn't make any but then
you start thinking like wait a minute
am i delicious you know I don't think I
am I think I work out too much
I'd be tough I'd be like a like a
[ __ ] like a cheap steak I feel but
you know what I mean you want to get
like a fat person sorry I got just
realize I gotta take some vitamin C here
so I don't get sick for my goddamn show
tonight in Iceland but yeah that's [ __ ]
just as making me think about stuff as
far as uh I think Joe DeRosa you get you
get a human being that like never works
out you know he's probably all marbled
and he smoked cigarettes he probably has
a smoky flavor
this is [ __ ] disgusting but I don't
know it's just [ __ ] you think when you
actually kill something anyway
but uh so yes so the next day we went
out we looked at like some hot springs
and the countryside and I had never done
that cuz I've only been nice in one
other time and I just kind of came in I
went to the Blue Lagoon spa and then I
just did my show and then that was it
and by the way I found a blue grid
lagoon spas just like the runoff
wastewater from some local [ __ ] plant
that they have where I don't know I
don't know what they do over here
there's something about the [ __ ] they
pumped the water and it seems really
clean energy over here but they're not
without their faults because I went down
to a comedy club and he did the [ __ ]
the one of the comedians did a joke
about you know getting the clap and and
he goes and you know Iceland Pete people
are just not not fazed by that like yeah
and and I was just like god dammit they
got a problem with that [ __ ] it's like
how do you have a [ __ ] problem with
it's like a cure to it why doesn't
everybody just take the [ __ ] pills or
whatever the [ __ ] you take it the shot
the ass what's when we get the
penicillin
no [ __ ] just wipe the [ __ ] out that's
what I would do if I would be running
[ __ ] over here
you know elect me keep Iceland clean and
let's get rid of the clap sorry I'm
drinking my [ __ ] emergencies all
right and then lay yeah I guess I am
then I took out we took a helicopter
tour up to an active volcano which
freaked me out I'm like wait a minute
they gonna be like lava spit nada
hearing [ __ ] and all it means by Actives
means it it erupted a thousand years ago
so it's still considered active like
that that's what blows my mind as far as
like how old the earth is and how long
it takes like there was like different
lava beds one was ten thousand years old
and one was a thousand years old and how
long it takes for the moss to grow and
then grass eventually to cover it up
it's really [ __ ] I felt like I was in
one of those Neil deGrasse Tyson [ __ ]
documentaries but um but we ended up we
landed right in like the the base of
this [ __ ] are like halfway up this
[ __ ] active volcano right and it had
all like these Hot Springs around it and
all that [ __ ] and the pilot was going
don't get too close to those things that
was when the guy said it gets up to like
like the steam gets up to like [ __ ]
400 degrees Celsius and for all you
Americans out there water boils at 100
degrees Celsius so it's four times what
was water boiling and whatever the
standard system 212 or something like
that so it's four times that you know
wait it's the steam so steam is even
hotter why do I act like I have a
[ __ ] science background I don't know
what it's [ __ ] hot as [ __ ] so we went
up there and uh you know I don't watch
Game of Thrones and I haven't watched I
watched one Lord of the Rings which I
thought they should have called it good
Lord of the Rings how long is this
[ __ ] movie dear
I've never been to a longer [ __ ]
movie that I can really think of maybe
cherry it's a fire you know when you
just go to something and you're just not
into it you're like when is this gonna
[ __ ] end I just don't understand
those [ __ ] sci-fi movies where people
just get into like weird beings with
funny voices and it's just like what am
I [ __ ] six years old this went from
being an adult movie now I'm watching
like the [ __ ] Muppets Take Manhattan
all right I know this [ __ ] jerk-off
with the blond hair and the horse isn't
gonna die he's got blond hair and he's
on a horse he's obviously the hero right
I vaguely remember that movie but I feel
like the lead looked like [ __ ] Ricky
Schroder Silver Spoons era and then they
had this obi-wan kenobe looking [ __ ]
guy who was nice but he'd you know you
just could tell like that my god that
guy smells like he's dying you know that
old person smell when they just start to
get that smell like they're like
decaying in front of you
this is such a weird podcast I already
actually talked about you know what Joe
DeRosa look what sort of steak he would
be sorry I've been out here for a while
by myself so anyway at night
I've been going up at the day of their
first comedy club out here in Reykjavik
called the secret cellar and I want to
thank everybody over there I randomly
ran into this comedian on the street I
forget his Icelandic name but I
abbreviated it to Alf so I want to thank
Icelandic Al the letting me know about
the show I went up at the Hard Rock Cafe
and then I I did a one show there and
then three shows at the secret cell and
had a great time except Saturday night I
went up and I wasn't feeling funny and I
went up and I wasn't doing well and
there was this woman in the crowd and
she was texting my whole set and I was
just like man it's like [ __ ] you know
20 people here you're I need you I need
you to pay attention and she's just like
yeah I'm not
- you're [ __ ] your gay phobic what
else did she say I had to write it down
ablest material
it was just like like I don't know what
that [ __ ] mean like I don't even know
what you're listening to you know people
who talk like that it's like why would
you go to a comedy club it's like you're
not there to laugh as much as you're
there to monitor what's being said it's
like you're going there to be offended
it's like anybody uses those [ __ ]
terms and you know did you see that
[ __ ] thing on the internet you know
with some restaurant the United States
and on the men's room and the women's
room on the men's room they had a
picture of Bruce Jenner and then on the
women's room door they had a picture of
Caitlyn Jenner which is [ __ ]
hilarious
and then of course it's immediately
looked at as like no that means you hate
gay people or you hate what is the
proper term transitioning people
whatever the [ __ ] you're supposed to say
it's like if that was in a gay club like
it would just be considered campy or
funny or like whatever but if it's in a
place where there's a lot of straight
people they just automatically think
that straight people hate gay people
when they do something like that it's a
pop culture joke and you know what I
love is putting Caitlyn Jenner on the
woman's dark woman's room door is
acknowledging the fact that you're
recognizing her as a woman I mean
there's so many positive ways that you
could look at that you could look at
that like hey this is a straight bar and
gay people are now in the mainstream
that they're being used as this [ __ ]
reference but no no no immediately it
was just like you know taken in this way
like and what I love is the person who
looks at how they take it is then
becomes the intention of the person that
put it up there you know and then they
start [ __ ] flipping out I'm also
convinced by the way that Twitter fans
the flames of their own [ __ ] stories
like they'll throw a subject out there
that nobody's talking about and then
they just say people are talking about
it
so then you click on it and you realize
there's barely anybody talking about it
and then it's still there the next day
cuz now it's trending and now you look
and there's be like [ __ ] 90,000 people
talking about it and it's just like
there's no way they don't have a [ __ ]
room you know in the offices of Twitter
where they're like we need to get this
trending we need something we need to
get going I don't know I I just I just
think everybody behaves like CNN and Fox
News now words it's not even like like
[ __ ] news and and then like the
people that would actually like think
about how [ __ ] dumb you would have to
be to actually leave comments on [ __ ]
like that okay but the people who are
dumb enough to leave comments on those
things then become the barometer
air-quote of what the [ __ ] people are
thinking which is it's such a crock of
[ __ ] like I saw that I'm not into the
superhero movies but I know one of them
just came out when I was Marvel ones
endgame thing you know and I guess there
was a gay character in there so there's
a gay character in there fantastic right
nope there's the thing did they go far
enough and I just when I read that I
just would I would assume okay not
saying I know how gay people think but I
would think a lot of gay people be
watching that going like why the [ __ ]
would you do that they finally put a gay
[ __ ] superhero in there and now what
we're gonna [ __ ] about it this is just
this is gonna make it more difficult I
don't know I just think extreme people
are the worst cuz they're extreme and
then they just get everybody yelling at
everybody it's like at what point is
everybody gonna get sick I just [ __ ]
screaming at each other I was actually
talking to Bartok last night he's whole
[ __ ] theory on how to uh Trump got
elected was it just was just made like
so much [ __ ] sense you know you know
like they tried to say like Oh Trump got
elected because a bunch of racist people
came out of the woodwork which is
[ __ ] hilarious one of the dumbest
theories I ever thought is like oh
really well where were all those racist
people the two previous elections when
they
voted against a black president they
waited till a white woman was running it
didn't even [ __ ] make sense and he
was saying just with the rise of the
extreme left it pushed people on the
Left who thought they were on the Left
to feel like they were like these people
are out of their [ __ ] minds and it
was just enough to tip the scale I don't
know then you got the whole [ __ ]
Russian [ __ ] I didn't [ __ ] listen
to that like am I really supposed to
believe that Russia that's the first
time they tampered with the [ __ ]
election and all this technology they
just waited until now and I'm supposed
to be shocked that's that that's
somebody a politician you know for the
betterment of their career got in bed
with a group of people they shouldn't
have got in bed with you mean like what
that like the pharmaceutical companies
like what the oil companies like the
people who make our [ __ ] food and
turned it into poison I mean like the
rush to get in bed with the Russians is
a pretty small [ __ ] leap and 11 out
like Trump gets all that [ __ ] who I'm
not a fan of but they just look the
other way when Obama is giving speeches
to banks that caused the 2008 economic
[ __ ] meltdown the same guys who said
were too big to fail it's okay for him
to go out there and take 300 thousand
dollars of their [ __ ] blood money but
for some reason because he has a [ __ ]
blue tie he's okay he's a [ __ ] rock
star
I'll never I swear I will never
understand
is it partisan politics is that how it
goes like a piece of [ __ ] is a piece of
[ __ ] and a paid off person is a paid off
person regardless of the color of their
[ __ ] time I also love how everybody
[ __ ] looks at Michelle Obama like
she's this feminist hero it's like she
went to a [ __ ] Ivy League school she
got a law degree and then she threw her
whole career away to stay at home and
support a [ __ ] husband like that's
the person that's doing an arena tour
why don't you get a couple of [ __ ]
chicks who open their own
cake storm and [ __ ] made something of
themselves right am i just out of my
[ __ ] mind I don't I don't get it
she's an inspiration she's so brave
every time you see as she's smiling and
clapping standing behind her [ __ ]
husband I agree with what he said
they're gay good David they're uh sorry
anyways maybe maybe maybe it's me maybe
it is me bill maybe if there's arena
full of people saying that she's an
inspiration maybe she's an inspiration
you freckled [ __ ] all right
maybe I'm wrong all right let's read
some [ __ ] advertising here honey
let's talk something about something we
can all agree on saving money the
reality is if you're not shopping around
you're probably not saving money well if
you're shopping you're inherently losing
money unless you're buying something you
really need I mean how far how far down
the [ __ ] rabbit hole we gonna go here
anyways so what if there was a way for
somebody to do the shopping around for
you
well that's exactly what oh honey
does honey is a free tool that you
download to your computer right
computers browser while you shop online
honey scans the internet for coupon
codes and other discounts then it
automatically applies the coupon with
the big biggest savings to your cart at
checkout like magic it works on over
20,000 sites like Amazon Nordstrom
j.crew Nike Best Buy Nordstrom said
Nordstrom twice Target Macy's and more
the pad in their resume there were two
Nordstrom's and it takes zero effort to
install just two click it's it clicks
and you're ready to start saving any
time you shop online instead of taking
my word for it listen to what actual
users have to say about honey this is
some person who may or may not work for
honey said I totally thought that honey
was a scam but I just got $300 worth of
bathing suits for a hundred and eighty
all right if that doesn't sound like the
most bullsh
tweet ever who spends $300 on [ __ ]
was that that [ __ ] Kate and Jake +8
whatever did she buy eight [ __ ]
bathing suits even if you bought eight
bathing suits for a [ __ ] kid how much
are they forty bucks a whack maybe eight
times four is what that's for twenty
right No
eight times five is forty Jesus Christ
320 all right this just sounds like this
is something you install on your
computer and then they track what you
buy if you don't give a [ __ ] like that's
probably how they make their money
all right look there's there's really no
reason not to use honey it's free to use
and easy to install on your computer and
just to click don't take it from me take
it from our listeners get honey for free
at join honeycomb / / that's joint
honeycomb / / hey honey the smart
shopping assistant that saves you time
and money that's genius then they track
what you buy and then these other
[ __ ] giant [ __ ] people pay them to
steer traffic towards them and then they
dump this [ __ ] that they want to get rid
of that's [ __ ] awesome it's a great
business model Sherry's berries ah look
who's back
Mother's Day is coming up and there's
absolutely nothing most of us wouldn't
do to make sure the special moms in our
life are happy talk about your mom it's
none of your business and why she
deserves to be happy this Mother's Day
cuz she's my mom I need to go any
farther than that could also be another
mom you admire send a gift to your
grandma sisters sister-in-law kids
godmother or or a milf down the street
there's all kinds of moms talk about the
best worst funniest reaction you've
received after sending a mother's take
my mother's a saint which she's never
made fun of me she's always says thank
you you know I say I love you mom you're
the best right there you go
Sherry's berries has a special Mother's
Day berries designed just for Mom they
are topped with chocolate chips pink
shimmer sugar and swivels describe how
much these gourmet goodies speaking of
[ __ ] like this you know there's
nucwear I out that's on Netflix that me
and my wife are addicted to because they
take it to a whole other level it used
to be the gay dudes came in and they
taught some straight dude to not dress
like he's in a [ __ ] caveman movie now
they've taken it to this other [ __ ]
level where they like told turn around
he's to hold people's lives I watched
them this one episode these two adorable
women right they got their secret family
recipe for barbecue sauce in Kansas City
not only do they give these people who
will make it a [ __ ] makeover to the
point they fix their teeth so the woman
could smile again she's literally crying
in a dental chair and then they've redid
their whole barbecue [ __ ] stand and
then got them to like jar their barbecue
sauce so they guess that was [ __ ] and
that that's a [ __ ] Mako from top to
bottom so so old freckles gives that
show five stars they watching it with my
wife it's you know with all the negative
[ __ ] out there it's a really it's a nice
feel-good show to watch Sherri's berries
alright pink shimmers sugar and swizzles
describe some describe how much these
gourmet goodies would make you're the
special mom in your life smile you
choose your delivery why do I have to
get so weird [ __ ] getting all up in
my goddamn life you choose your delivery
date to ensure mom gets your gift of
Sherry's berries exactly when you want
or to and your satisfaction is always
guaranteed don't wait until the last
minute on this one visit berries dot-com
to order a freshly dipped strawberries
gross starting at $19.99 for the moms in
your life to make mom really happy you
can double the berries for just $10 more
why is this all the whole underlying
[ __ ] Freudian [ __ ] of this is just
creeping me out Mother's Day is Sunday
May 12 to really satisfy your mother one
who [ __ ] rights this is gross May 12
so visit berries calm that
berr IES comm click on the microphone in
the upper right corner enter my code bar
that's Barry's comm click the microphone
code part yeah it's chocolate-covered
strawberries
make your mom happy all right you love
her she loves you she raised you that's
all the copy and need berries calm all
right fan oh wow that was it that was
all I had for this week all right fan
from India oh by the way they yeah
barnicke went up but he did a couple of
[ __ ] new jokes that he absolutely
[ __ ] murdered the guy just walked on
stage like he's like hey he's like this
is my first European show and just went
up there it took me back to the first
time I ever saw Joe I saw him in the
[ __ ] we're in the punch line in San
Francisco and Molly schminke had booked
him you know one of the last godmothers
of [ __ ] stand-up comedy someone he
actually cares somebody who actually has
the [ __ ] eye and ear to actually
recognize when somebody's good rather
than just some [ __ ] mouth-breathing
dope running a club she you know used to
try to pair the local talent with
whatever headliner was coming in so she
thought that I would like Joe and like
Joe went onstage and San Francisco was
always ahead of the curve when it came
to like just being like I don't know
smart and maybe liberal to a fault back
when being liberal to a fault was
actually you know those people were cool
you know before it became like this like
liberal to a fault and now I'm gonna
[ __ ] try to destroy your career
because you have the audacity to not
think exactly what I think you know yeah
before they became [ __ ] right wing
lunatics anyway so Joe went up there and
he just [ __ ] doing his act and he was
this Pittsburgh guy in San Francisco and
the crowd was just like what the [ __ ] at
first and he just was not gonna pull
back at all and I felt the crowd
just be like alright I guess he's not
stopping and they just went along for
the ride and I mean who was just like I
[ __ ] love this guy and last night
when I saw him to stand up in Iceland he
just [ __ ] went up same thing Joey be
is Joey B no matter where he is and he
just went up and did his [ __ ] and the
crowd was just like this guys they
[ __ ] loved him and he tried out two
new jokes which really got me inspired
here cuz I have to come up with some new
material before my special comes out
anyway fan from India hey Billy blue
balls I'm a big fan of your stand-up and
I've watched all of your specials and f
is for family is [ __ ] awesome thank
you very much anyway let me get to the
point I am 17 years old and first saw
you during one of the Conan interview
immediately became a big fan as you were
the only guy in Hollywood who had the
same thought process as I say I knew I'd
like people from India I had such a good
time when I was over there I just get
scared to go back because I you know I
had to get a [ __ ] piece of paper to a
work visa I had to send my [ __ ] visa
to San Francisco which is my passport
sorry to get some sort of work visa and
then when I went to India I had to get a
piece of paper that would allow me to
leave you know [ __ ] scary that is
when you're on the other side of the
[ __ ] globe and you're in a country
nobody looks like you and you got to get
a [ __ ] you know it's like these guys
not gonna let me leave right then I had
to go to like that the [ __ ] I don't
know what it was the embassy typed place
not the embassy I don't know what it was
it was like they're [ __ ]
International DMV and I went in there
and they didn't let the promoter go and
I had to go in by myself I didn't speak
the [ __ ] language and I'm sitting
there with some chick from Afghanistan
we're both look at each other laughing
like then I'm gonna let us leave and I
was in there for like half the [ __ ]
day and they finally gave me the piece
of paper and the entire time you know in
the back of my head I'm just thinking
like cuz the promoter told me he said
you know there's a chance they won't
validate this because I said the
I said it to the lady there I go okay so
I got this piece of paper so this means
I can leave right and they do this thing
over in India it's [ __ ] hilarious
except when you're talking about leaving
the country and you need a definitive
answer
they got this hilarious thing they do
where you ask him a question and they
don't nod their head yes or shake their
head no they kind of do like this
bobblehead thing which is I guess their
equivalent to shrugging their shoulders
like I don't [ __ ] know so fortunately
I was taking a red-eye and the airport
wasn't wasn't packed and I kind of just
go illud my way through like I started
getting angry at the guy because the guy
was doing the bobblehead thing I'm go
dude I went to the thing I got the thing
I got to get out of here and he's
sitting there going like this I'm like
buddy the planes leaving let's go come
on give me give me that I got to go and
in my head I'm like Bill what are you
doing this guy and these guys gonna
detain you you're losing your [ __ ] here
at the [ __ ] Mumbai International
Airport but he let us [ __ ] go and the
whole time I was walking down the plane
I was just waiting for this hand to
reach out and just on my shoulder and
tell me that I'd been detained because
they didn't let some some singer out I
forget what her name was it was like a
Norah Jones level I'm not saying it was
her but was that level singer some
beautiful you know pop star piano
playing goddess and they didn't let her
out an old [ __ ] the bald ginger I'm
like there's no [ __ ] way they're
letting me out but somehow I got past
that guy and I didn't feel comfortable
until after we connected and Dubai and I
was still doing the math which kind of
helped me forget that we were flying
over Iraq at that point I believe I was
like are they gonna [ __ ] this isn't
me some [ __ ] where I get to the United
States and then that's and then they
send me back I just remember when I
cleared customs in the US I was so
[ __ ] relieved but having said that
when I went to India like there's some
of the funniest just naturally funniest
[ __ ] people I ever met they were such
ball-breaking [ __ ] and I mean that
in a good way
like the comics over there were just
breaking my
and trying to get me in trouble when I
was you should talk about this and all
of this [ __ ] when I was over there so
anyway so this guy course this guy
watching me on cone and he thinks yeah I
don't know what it is I don't know what
it is when I was in India I was like
these are like tan Irish people all
right you helped me when I was really
low and I wanted to thank you for that
I'm sure you get [ __ ] on [ __ ] you get a
[ __ ] ton of these sorts of emails but I
want you to know that all your fans
appreciate you okay at some point you
got to pull up on the compliments here
and get to the question he said I want
to be a doctor and yes you may think oh
the stereotypical Indian but that's my
passion man dude you guys are so [ __ ]
smart that the offensive stereotype was
like what you think I'm gonna be a
doctor
that's like a badge that's not a bad
stereotype is I think the bad stereotype
is if I thought you gonna be a [ __ ]
snake charmer you know or beating an
elephant that didn't want to work for
you if yeah I think that that would be a
stereotype I mean they say you're gonna
be a doctor that's like a positive thing
right anyways can you give some
encouraging advice on ladies as I know
you know a lot of them I really don't I
[ __ ] appreciate the [ __ ] out of you
man come to India bangle bangle bangle
or to be precise and go [ __ ] yourself
can you give me some encouraging advice
on ladies all right well now you got me
in my head where it's just like the fact
that you yet another Indian guy who's
going to excel and met in medicine is
that just like boring to women over
there why don't you do this why don't
you become the jacked Indian dude who's
gonna be a [ __ ] doctor
and make a great goddamn living like
what the [ __ ] is the problem with that
you know if you know through line with
women around the [ __ ] world is you
can't make them happy I mean what more
does this guy gotta [ __ ] do I don't
know just I don't know become good I
guess you what you have to do
from what you're suggesting is that
you're yet another Indian guy who's
gonna be a doctor right so what is
exciting about that so I imagine these
Indian women are just rolling their eyes
like Oh God like and then it's like what
do you have to be you got to be like a
neurosurgeon to get them excited you
know are you guys so smart over there
that literally like being like a
proctologist they look at you like
you're [ __ ] you know cleaning out
dumpsters you know what give you some
encouraging advice on the ladies I mean
I know it takes a lot to be a doctor so
I don't know if you have time for a
hobby but yeah I don't know learn how to
play an instrument go to the gym and get
[ __ ] jacked - so you got to do
something to separate yourself from the
[ __ ] the slew I guess of Indian
doctors over there you seem like you got
a sense of humor do you know what the
what the [ __ ] do you need to do you
gotta beg for your [ __ ] dinner here I
mean you're a goddamn doctor what woman
wouldn't want to [ __ ] that's not
enough over there I don't know this is a
weird topic because when I was over
there I saw this [ __ ] t-shirt that
said it said real men don't rape so I
don't know what the [ __ ] going on over
there if you're a doctor and you're not
going around raping women I mean doesn't
that put your [ __ ] you got to be at
least a second-round draft pick Tovar
there huh I don't know I was only there
for a day and a half you know and I
spent half of one of my days trying to
[ __ ] get a goddamn piece of paper to
tell me that I can leave I still
remember that [ __ ] guy at the airport
thank God thank God I got there late it
was a [ __ ] red-eye flight and it was
like nobody there I'm like look I got
the piece of paper just I'm [ __ ]
going basically what I said the guy
sitting there doing the bobblehead thing
and he finally gave me the thing back
and he [ __ ] stamped
no I cleared that it was weird he wasn't
like his customs it was just some
[ __ ] guy behind a podium
it was so unnerving when I think about
it I still get nervous I'm gonna ask my
agent cuz I would love to go back over
there again it's like I said I really
enjoyed I don't know it was like India's
like it's a [ __ ] special placement I
don't know what it is I mean it's an
environmental disaster there's just too
many like [ __ ] people but other than
that you know if you're gonna have a
billion people in the country they you
know it's just amazing how [ __ ] cool
they were and they were that jammed in
with each other cuz I if it was like
that in America we'd [ __ ] kill each
other I don't know what the [ __ ] is
wrong with that I remember reading this
book some book about war and and they
were just talking about the different
groups of people different armies and
the Americans were the only ones that
when they were detained with each other
they'd get to a point where they would
kill each other that they had like
violence like American versus American
violence like they didn't have like
Australian versus Australian or whatever
like that at least according to this
[ __ ] book and I was just so yeah well
you know we are a nation of lunatics but
you would think that Australia cos
Australia has got a lot of the same sort
of history you know well you got a bunch
of lunatics [ __ ] leave England go to
a new land there's people there and then
they eventually [ __ ] do horrible
things to them and then take over so you
think that I don't know I don't know why
we're such [ __ ] maniacs maybe I don't
know all right
Icelander about Iceland hey Bill I'm
from Iceland and I've heard you state on
your previous podcast that Iceland
wouldn't take any [ __ ] from bankers
and put them to jail that this is
absolute [ __ ]
well I thought that you guys put like
you were the only ones who put bankers
and politicians in jail after 2008
that's the story I was told so I would
love to hear your story
some who were involved with the economic
crash of 2008 were tried but most of but
most if not all of them got away with it
well I was surprised with the jail
sentences they weren't that long a
simple Google search would reveal to you
that this is not the case I'm right you
don't need to slap me around do I have
to Google search everything that people
tell me today many of these mens are
doing the exact same thing they were up
to before the crash oh yeah well welcome
to the United States because they're
doing it again all these stupid [ __ ]
giant high-rises that they're building
we'll just put the money over here and
that makes it different because this
time it's not houses it's buildings for
example life pension funds are mandatory
in Iceland about 10% of your monthly
salary goes to these funds that are
supposed to provide for you when you get
old
a small group of people are in charge of
those funds and they invest in all kinds
of things mostly real estate they buy up
all new real estate and then rent them
out for outrageous prices to the common
man every year they tell us they're
making so much profit that there's
leftovers for the executives to get
insane bonuses meanwhile old people are
getting reduced pensions because quote
reasons most recent news I've seen from
these pension plans is that they're
going to raise the mandatory monthly
payment from 10% to 14% because it's
good for you yeah dude they're [ __ ]
criminals they're [ __ ] criminals and
you know what it is they just pay off
the politicians and they look the other
way that's like in my country where now
if you make over ten million dollars
they want to charge 70 percent [ __ ]
tax rather than go after the criminals
that have put us into that [ __ ]
financial position yeah my whole country
is like a bunch of zombies just clapping
every time they have troops go by going
I support the troops I support the
troops and you're not allowed to
question or be like what the [ __ ] are we
doing when is this going to be over
we're bankrupt
what the [ __ ] does anybody have a plan
if you do that people look at you like
you don't support the troops and you
don't appreciate the sacrifices it all
gets balled up into that and you cannot
have a [ __ ] intelligent conversation
about it it's [ __ ] brutal like we are
we are we're beyond bankrupt we've
surpassed the legal amount of debt that
we can get and we debt like our solution
was just keep raising the amount of debt
that we could bet get in he said anyway
I would I just wanted to tell you
Iceland is not the utopia everyone
thinks of this can't wait to see you're
set in Iceland and I hope your act isn't
as [ __ ] as you say it is sincere
sincerely go [ __ ] yourself a fellow
country my son well I gotta be honest me
to do this is one of most expensive
[ __ ] places I've ever been to in my
life like you know I went out and I got
to [ __ ] medium pizzas and two glasses
of water and it was like 54,000 [ __ ]
crona's or 50 I don't know what the
[ __ ] was oh you always just moved the
decimal point over a couple of fifty
four hundred so it's basically fifty
four bucks for two goddamn pizzas
mediums not even large enough just like
this is like [ __ ] annoyingly
expensive over here
the fact that the bankers don't go to
jail the fact that all they do is
control money and they're not even tough
and they don't even have like weaponry
like they it's good there's gonna have
to be I don't know a point where people
rise up against that [ __ ] you would like
to think but I will say though the fact
that we spent so much [ __ ] so much of
our energy arguing about [ __ ] like you
know was the gay character in the action
movie gay enough you know what jay-z
said about gentrifying neighborhoods or
[ __ ] you know like gender-neutral
bathrooms and just the [ __ ] that we're
[ __ ] arguing about I'm not saying that
there's not points to be made there's
not improvements that need to be made in
those areas but like as far as like a
priority it's like your house is on fire
and you're talking about how you need to
buy a new toaster you know or we really
need to [ __ ] mop the kitchen floor or
something it's like is that the priority
system which I actually think is no
different than the bankers the same way
the bankers are being [ __ ] selfish
and taking all the goddamn money and
giving themselves like just obscene
[ __ ] bonuses I feel like regular
everyday people are the same way we're
all they give a [ __ ] is about problems
that affect them rather than the big
problems that affect all of us you know
it should be all about [ __ ] you know
getting bankers under control and in and
global warming that's those those are
the two biggest [ __ ] things that that
should be on the table right now you
know not you know [ __ ] telling
twenty-something year old white women
that they're brave because they sent out
a tweet that's just what I think
anyways
[ __ ] thank you is the next one good
morning Billy old Billy oh [ __ ] charm
love your podcast you're the best yada
yada yada that's the way I like to have
a compliment get that [ __ ] out of the
way and let's go all right yeah anyways
I'd like you guys are already anyways
like me how I say I just want to thank
you due to the fact that last night I
went to a bar at Buffalo Wild Wings got
off work and decided to drink a few
brewskies and as I was watching one of
many TVs
I saw a zip recruiter ad and it made me
being a podcast listener what and and
hello and me being a podcast listener
said it a little too loud and this chick
caught it knew where it was from an
ignite
acknowledged oh you said zip and then
she went recruiter oh that's so [ __ ]
cool she had just gotten off work and
went to Buffalo Wild Wings to relax and
eat some wings and there was an empty
seat in between us therefore I offered
her to sit next to me and she said yeah
sure I offered a beer and she said I'll
take one but it's okay you don't have to
pay for it so I didn't Jesus Christ is
[ __ ] found a unicorn here however we
were chatting up and 98 percent of the
topic was all about the podcast in two
hours past of just talking and drinking
and there was a cinema in the mall so I
asked if she wanted to go watch endgame
and she said yeah went to the cinema and
had a great time
we ended up exchanging numbers and this
morning she texted me good morning we
should hang out sometime next weekend so
I'm hoping this could be the start of
something good can't wait to tell the
wife ha ha I'm joking Jesus Christ you
just scared the [ __ ] out of me
anyways I just thought I should take the
time to thank you electronically thanks
and for read thanks for reading and go
[ __ ] yourself alright awesome look at
that making a love connection I'm gonna
i'm a regular chuck wall
guys love about Chuck Woolery on [ __ ]
love connection aside from his amazing
head of hair his tan and his [ __ ]
perfect teeth when someone would say
something crazy and he would kind of put
his hand up to his head and then show
off his [ __ ] Rolex presidential just
blinding you at home he was the [ __ ]
man when the ladies loved him
all right conspiracy corner huge Chuck
Woolery Finn hey Billy Bruins oh
speaking of which huh but those Bob
about your Boston Bruins and a my
condolences condolence my condolences to
[ __ ] Maple Leaf fans man Jesus Christ
I mean I mean I actually you have to say
our maple leaf Ann's the best fans in
all of sports you name one other [ __ ]
team that has had the track record for
51 [ __ ] years that they have had I'm
just breaking their fans hearts over and
over and over and over again and you
still you can't get a ticket you know
I've done that NHL radio show so I got
some hookups so any time I want to go to
NHL game if I want to be a [ __ ] and call
somebody up I can get free tickets I can
do that anywhere in the league except
Toronto Toronto the NHL front office is
like we can't even get tickets despite
they've lost three game sevens this
decade alone and still you can't get a
ticket we had to stand out on the street
and [ __ ] scalp him like the old days
so it was a hell of a series and like I
said and I meant it if the you guys beat
the Bruins I was gonna root for you guys
so having said that the Boston slam is
still alive I mean it's a [ __ ] long
shot I'm trying to think of a city ever
won the Stanley Cup in an NBA title in
the same year I don't think that's ever
happened I know the Bruins went to the
finals in 87 and the Celtics went
Defiant we both lost that year we lost
to the Lakers and we lost to the
Edmonton Oilers
and I gotta tell you if you are gonna
lose those are too [ __ ] respectable
losses to the Magic Johnson Showtime
Lakers and the [ __ ] talk in 1987 the
Wayne Gretzky Mark Messier Edmonton
Oilers
so anyways I'm missing all of this [ __ ]
but Bart Knicks out here so he's gonna
get me caught up
he found a sports bar last night but
I've missed all of the missed Game seven
of the Bruins Toronto and I did it yeah
I just had my buddies just texting me
letting me know when there was a score
and then they'd send me a video and I
would watch the score whatever the goal
but uh I know that the Bruins in
Columbus are 1 1 I heard it got real
chippy in the second game and it's
killing me because I know it's just
gonna be a [ __ ] sick ass physical
[ __ ] awesome series and I'm also I
want to see Tortorella way he's got like
he's reminded me of from what I've been
reading is he's kind of changed his
approach he's not as much as the
hard-ass because like what I saw him
smiling after they won game 2 and tamp I
was like who the [ __ ] is that guy he
looks like he's having fun and it
reminded me of Dick Vermeil when he went
too hard with the Eagles before Super
Bowl 15 and he kind of burned him out he
felt and it affected their their play
and then when he came back with the Rams
in 99 he had more fun and they won
so it's reminding me of that story so
that's gonna happen I want to see it but
if you play in my Bruins I got a root
against you obviously so and I've missed
all the Celtics I just heard Kyrie
Irving and everybody's finally got on
the same page that white kid we got from
Utah was his name Hayward Haywood I got
a kid I don't know who anybody is
anymore I heard he had a big game game 1
playing Milwaukee and that takes him
back to a kid there's a kid man the
Celtics used to always have to go
through [ __ ] Milwaukee
you know Sidney Moncrief and all of
those [ __ ] guys I wanted even was
Jack Sikma on that team was was he
always in Seattle I can't remember
anyways emailing you from Toronto
and no I'm not here to whine about the
playoffs new jersey devil fan instead I
even emailing you hang on my screen just
went away emailing you to get your
advice on this ad achill I came across
this past week the self-checkouts are
bad enough but now every self is taking
a scan of your face I'm sure they have
some software on their computers that
are hooked up with their security
cameras that can do facial recognition
but this is next-level [ __ ]
they'll be scanning your face while
you're skimming through which hemorrhoid
creams you should get dude this is yeah
this is the [ __ ] that they're [ __ ]
doing man is and these politicians are
just sitting back letting them do it
cameras that guess your age and sex are
coming to store shelves dude I swear to
god I'm gonna start shopping with like
wearing a [ __ ] clown mask you know or
you know you know like when Asian people
are getting sick anyway that mask cuz
they're considering enough to try not to
get other people sick just walk in with
the [ __ ] surgical masks on and just
do that and then they'll come up with
some sort of bill that they connect to
9/11 that they're they're afraid and it
makes other people unsettled and they
don't know if you're [ __ ] terrorists
when you come in dressed like [ __ ]
Clarabelle I didn't want to [ __ ] read
that that's just [ __ ] ridiculous and
I love when you watch like corporate
news and then like well that's
interesting and you just see them their
mouths gagged with all the [ __ ] money
they have [ __ ] shoved up their asses
there's such I just I gotta be honest to
you I cannot get over what [ __ ]
[ __ ] people are why don't you know
what I mean
when it comes to like that's why you got
to work for yourself so you can just say
what the [ __ ] you thinking instead of
your [ __ ] ball as human beings grow a
[ __ ] dick and deliver the news and
can you have a Walter Cronkite moment
and just say what the [ __ ] you're
thinking just to see somebody do that on
the news even if you
got [ __ ] fired you're gonna start a
podcast you're gonna make [ __ ] more
money yeah I'm the [ __ ] news guy that
actually says what he thinks about the
news rather than just reading this
unsettling [ __ ] and just being a [ __ ]
team player I don't know as much as you
don't maybe like [ __ ] Glenn Beck or
whatever that guy got fired and he went
up that guy's making zillions of dollars
but no one's really listening to him are
they I don't know maybe it's a bad idea
don't [ __ ] listen to me for career
advice anyways he's just a [ __ ]
sometimes all right here's an email from
a lady which I love but we don't get to
hear from the ladies it's a [ __ ]
goddamn sausage fest over here [ __ ]
bratwurst on the fire every goddamn
podcast here he's just a [ __ ] some
time what the hell is it sometimes on
Friday nights I like to watch scary
movies wit my husband and kids my
husband always gets pissed off halfway
through the movie about me being a
horrible parent and Usher's the children
out of the room these are thriller
movies not gore or extreme violence our
boys are 7 and 11
they are well-adjusted good boys they
are on the honor roll at school we are
involved parents and eat a family dinner
together every night all right well it
looks like you're crushing it so far we
are not parents that expose them to
everything and anything but they do get
spoken to about real [ __ ] my issue is my
husband lets them play fort night call
of duty listen to Eminem and all
alternative rock music yeah well what
the [ __ ] they can't watch a thriller at
that point they even hear your podcast
I'm [ __ ] sick of being told I'm a bad
parent well first of all if you're gonna
try to get your partner to hear what
you're saying and how you feel you can't
say that they're a bad parent who the
[ __ ] gonna be listening after that
you're gonna get offended you're gonna
get defensive and then that's gonna be
end of any sort of logical conversation
right anyways I want to said because I
want to expose them to scary movies on
occasion
it's something my sister and I always
did growing up with my dad and we were
not messed up from it my husband says
that because I work with children as a
school administrator I should know not
to expose their minds to this because it
will [ __ ] them up and they're playing
fighting in what fortnight is but I
imagine that's one of those gun games
and I listen to Eminem's and in this
[ __ ] podcast I wouldn't let my kid
listen to this podcast
my husband says oh wow he will persevere
on this topic until I want to punch him
in the face
instead he ruins the movie and the kids
leave the room and I go to bed what are
your thoughts on this am ia horrible mom
keep in mind if there's a sex scene it's
fast forwarded thank you he's a
hypocrite
it's like he can expose him to [ __ ] up
[ __ ] because he's into that stuff for
tonight call of duty listening to Eminem
I don't want alt-rock has to do with
anything but I know I think they'll be
alright you know and I used to watch
those [ __ ] movies I was fine like I
understand him not wanting them to watch
those movies I get that but not if
you're also letting him do the other
stuff so what I would try to do is just
sit down say listen I want to talk to
you about this because we keep fighting
about these movies and this is a
question I don't want you to get upset
I'm just asking cuz I want to find a
solution and not have a fight here why
do you feel that thrillers movies are
bad for them to watch but it's not bad
for them to play violent video games or
listen to Eminem or the Monday morning
podcast and if he hops and pops and gets
mad then then he's a [ __ ] baby and
what you have to do then is keep your
cool and as he flips out
don't flip up
you have to remain calm and just sit
there and be like you know you got to be
like Ben Kingsley and sexy beasts like
why you swearing I'm not swearing you
stay in that [ __ ] thing like why are
you raising your voice I'm not raising
voice I'm trying to find a solution here
and you you know your name calling and
you're doing all of this stuff like this
isn't acceptable maybe you know when you
calm down and you want to talk about
this all right I am more than willing if
you can give me a logical reason I'm
more than willing to stop doing this but
if you can't give me a logical reason
I'm going to continue the tradition of
watching the movies like I did with my
dad with my kids and you're not gonna
come in and ruin them and tell me that
I'm a horrible parent yeah you know what
you need to put your foot down
sweetheart okay
yeah like that I mean it's far from
where I'm sitting that guy doesn't have
a [ __ ] leg to stand on I would I
would think that I'm sitting there
watching some stupid thriller movie is
not as bad as [ __ ] playing a video
game where you're shooting people
because I'm advised to play video games
right and they were just taking up too
much of my time so I literally unplugged
the [ __ ] thing and stuck it in the
back of the closet and I unplugged all
the wires cuz I knew I would never be
able to figure it back you know how to
do it I didn't keep the instruction
booklet and I never watched him again I
never played him again but like I used
to play this sniper game and when you
press down on this one button it would
have that you know the sniper X and it
would like focus in on somebody's head
and I played that game so much over the
course of a week I walked out into the
streets of New York and I was looking at
people and I was seeing that sniper
thing on their [ __ ] head now I'm not
a lunatic so I didn't do anything but it
was just like what the [ __ ] is that like
I don't I never watched a thriller movie
you know and then walked outside and
thought about you know stabbing somebody
or shooting somebody you know why cuz I
think the [ __ ] movie it's you're not
as connected to it and it's over in like
90 minutes where like you can spend a
day playing a video game just
appear down a rabbit hole yeah all right
well you know I mean granite all I heard
was your side of the story but for one
I'm hearin i 100% think you're in the
right so good luck with that put your
foot down but I'm telling you don't it
seems like your husband is an emotional
person so when you get with somebody
like that you you it's up to you to
drive the ship of emotion you have to
stay [ __ ] calm and if they're flipping
out and you're not flipping out then
they just look like an idiot I don't
know that's basically it all right plow
ahead here last one found out my sister
had it has different dad need advice
okay dear Billy ball gag I need your
advice in a very difficult situation I'm
in my 30s and my sister's a year older
than me our parents divorced when we
were teenagers and we've we have always
been close I get along very good with my
dad and I feel like I'm his little twin
my looks personality work ethic all
resembled my father well that's great my
sister looks nothing like him but
resembles my mom I recently got too
drunk with my dad and his wife and he
were complaining about my sister always
calling him asking for money he's always
treated her strangely oh my god and
recently admitted he's not my sisters my
sister's father what and that my mother
had an affair with his best friend holy
[ __ ]
his friend he's talking about looks like
my sister and they share many
personality traits so your dad hung in
there after that after his best friend
banged his [ __ ] wife and then raised
the kid oh my god my sister doesn't know
but my mother admitted it and I recently
found a letter from the 1980s from my
mother talking about the whole thing is
it my place to tell her or to talk to my
parents and see if they feel like
telling her what the hell should I do
what would you do I love you cartoon in
the podcast I've seen
episode okay thank you very much all
that nice stuff um yeah I would talk to
you your mom I talked to your mom and
I'd say she needs to know all right and
then I would see what the [ __ ] happened
and and if she refuses to tell her then
I would talk to a professional not some
[ __ ] [ __ ] job telling comedian
because that's that's a tough one i I I
don't know what to tell you on that one
but my advice to you would be to talk to
your mom and be like look all right I
was cool with you know keeping the Santa
Claus secret but this is a different
ballgame if you know what I mean yeah
that's what I would do all right that's
kind of a bummer to end on but uh wow
that's that's [ __ ] bananas Jesus
Christ all right I gotta get my head
together man I got to do a show tonight
and Rinca pick eight and then I go on
tour I go on tour and then I'm in
Copenhagen and then Stockholm Sweden and
then [ __ ] Oslo and I'm in [ __ ]
Helsinki and then I'm in Amsterdam then
I have a day off and then I end up in
Tel Aviv in Israel all right then you
know else is [ __ ] patrolling these
waters over here all things comedies
host of something's burning the
shirtless wonder one of the most fun
[ __ ] people I've ever met in my life
Bert Kreischer so definitely go out and
check him out
as I believe I just saw a video of him
he just ended in Manchester England and
I guarantee you he's got a bunch of new
friends out there if any if any city was
waiting for [ __ ] Bert Kreischer to
show up it's Manchester England but he's
he's going to be tearing through
Scandinavia
so get your fitness goals where they
need to be because you're about ready to
see the [ __ ] the Machine Bert
Kreischer all right go [ __ ] yourselves
I'll check in on you on Thursday